hey everyone today i'm going to show you
guys in another hd tutorial how to
upgrade your current version of safari
whether it's for a mac or for a pc
as you can see apple software update has
just detected that version 3.2.2
of safari web browser available for my
computer
i'm actually going to use this i'm going
to go into safari and actually show you
what version i have now so if you go to
help and about safari you can see i have
version 3.2.1
so we're going to upgrade by going to
apple
and simply go to the downloads section
again like we did when we are installing
the original safari and look it says
version 3.2 so we're going to click on
it
and it says download version 3.2 now and
i'm 100 confident that safari will
detect that i already have version 3.2.1
and download and install version 3.2.2
and save all my fav favorites and
bookmarks etc over with this
so select safari for windows xp or vista
and i'm going to uncheck that box and
avoid putting in my email address and
hit download safari now
the dialog box comes up and safari
setup.exe is downloading i'll exit out
of the actual safari browser
so here it is downloading it's 1.5 megs
a second pretty good
all right now that we see that it's done
i'm just going to exit out of the
downloads window
and it says
safari.exe do you really want to run
this file i will hit yes
and exit out of here
now uac just came up and i hit okay
because i obviously want to allow this
program to run on my computer
and that is pretty much all you need to
do to enable the um the installation of
safari we'll get a dialog box um
finishing up our installation here so
that we can actually use version 3.2.2
so i'm going to open up safari again
actually i'm not going to open it up
because i want to watch the installation
process here
all right here is welcome to the safari
installer
click next and accept the terms and
license agreement and hit next again
this is where you can select where it
will actually be installed i'm i'm fine
with installing program files safari
because that's where my current version
is
hit next and now it's going to actually
install safari all the program features
that i already had and all the plugins
and add-ons that i showed you how to get
will still be in your version of safari
so don't worry about that
all right here it is finishing up
registering my product and removing the
old temporary files that it used so
while it was installing so now it has
the full blown new safari and i'll just
go ahead and show you how to put an icon
on my desktop for me obviously they all
want you to have that icon on your desk
so now it's validating install and
finishing everything up so uh
hopefully this will be done in a second
and this has been successfully installed
on your computer
so i'm going to un ship i'm going to
uncheck the box that's open safari after
this exits i'm just going to finish
now what i'm going to do is right click
and unlock my rocket dock real quick so
i can remove the old safari icon and
place in the new safari icon i'm not
sure if this actually makes a difference
but hopefully it will that will launch
safari version 3.2.2
so here we go first launch of safari 3.2
you can see it kept my old windows error
theme it kept my old all my favorites
here even still has all the uh the logos
and everything that i used
so
that is how you easily install version
3.2.2 of safari on your current computer
and if i obviously go to help and about
safari you see here i'm using version
3.2.2
uh let's go
bring up a quick acid three test
just to see if it does any better i
showed you webkit got a 100 out of 100
and again linked has failed and 75.
so if you really want to make safari
that much better i would go with webkit
guys and i'll just go ahead and watch my
video on how to download and install and
use the safari webkit browser which does
get a 100 out of 100
and is quite a bit faster so i hope you
like this tutorial on how to upgrade
your version of safari without using any
other type of software
um just windows installer and a simple
apple website interface so if you like
this tutorial go ahead and subscribe and
many more videos to come go ahead and if
you have an idea just give me a personal
message and i'll get to it i'll do my
best thanks for watching guys peace